good morning believe nation today's
message is make your own industry over
to you Martin Scorsese make your own
industry recreate movies don't pay
attention to industry do your own thing
you want the work to be seen but it
doesn't have to be at the Odeon you know
no more that's all different that's all
against another ancient world that type
of film or not even that type of film
the the communal experience is always
important you can make a film on a
camera the size of that doorknob and
still show it to 1600 people in an
audience it's still a great communal
experience you know it doesn't
necessarily mean it has to cost over 100
million pounds
I think this rule isn't just for people
who are making movies is it's for
entrepreneurs it's a special branch of
Mirth because what we do is create our
own thing if you are just selling the
same product as everybody else you're
gonna lose because somebody's always
gonna beat you one price or the big
companies are gonna beat you with their
branding and reputation in advertising
dollars if you are just selling the same
thing as everybody else you will lose
you need to create something different
and that's where your edge comes in
that's where the entrepreneurial
thinking comes in that's where the
creativity comes in you have to find
something that somebody else isn't doing
add your own secret sauce into it and
that's where your success comes out if I
look at my youtube channel as an example
I desperately wanted to learn more from
famous entrepreneurs I feel like I
didn't have enough in my network in my
circle people to learn from and so I
wanted to learn from some of the Great's
of the Great's and so I put together
these videos for me to learn selfishly
and I share with you guys and thankfully
you enjoy it and that's become this
whole beast now that's grown that has
four hundred thousand subscribers and
you guys want more content and I'm so
thrilled that you are loving it just
like I'm loving it for myself as well
and that is different nobody else is
doing this on YouTube but now a whole
bunch of other people have sprung up
copying exactly what I'm doing or taking
my exact
and use it on their channel and I don't
care people said you care about those
guys I don't care people who just copy
me will never will never win they'll
never beat me like you can't just copy
somebody else you can model somebody
else you can learn from their success
and apply something I work for them to
your business but unless you're adding
your own little creativity to it unless
you're taking something I work with
somebody else and tweaking it so it
works for you in a different way then
you're never gonna be successful you're
never gonna reach the top you're gonna
have that big impact so I want you to
focus on how you can create your own
industry what is a new innovative thing
that you are bringing whether it's the
product or the service where this
execution was in your operation what is
it that's different that you bring to
the market and something that uniquely
is like you you're injecting yourself
into it because people can't copy you
right people can't be another you there
will never be another Michael Jordan
right there never be another Anthony
Robbins oh never be another Bill Gates
or whoever you look up to you need to be
the first you and create your own
industry so the question of day today is
how are you creating your own industry
what's so different and unique and
special about you and what you're
bringing to your business leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to who selenium I said oh
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book it really means a lot to me
those are you guys watching if you want
to change at a shadow in your future
video make sure to grab a copy of the
book and email in your seat so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
I spray so give me go